- So, after about a month of preparation
and with about 3000 unwrapped Starburst,
we are ready to steamroll our artwork.
Under that tarp is the artwork.
(popping)
So, let's roll.
Who's ready to steamroll some Starburst?!
- [Everyone] Wooo!
(everyone cheering)
Steamroll!
- I feel like this is where I live now.
- Still working on the grin.
I thought we were gonna have
this all done at this point.
- So we've been unwrapping
Starbursts for the last six hours
with the hope that tomorrow we
can put it down in a pattern,
squish it with a steamroller
and it turns into beautiful artwork.
But, who knows?
- Hey, I'm finished with the drawing.
Do you guys wanna come see it?
- [Everyone] Yes.
- [Woman] Wow, it's beautiful.
- Do you guys feel weird
that we spent all week prepping for it,
gonna happen tomorrow
and it could be nothing.
- Um, you know what?
We're gonna survive tomorrow
regardless of whether this works or not.
I think it's gonna work.
- Alright, so let's go to sleep
and just see what happens tomorrow.
(playful music)
- What's happening?
- We are placing candy to be smooshed.
Hopefully, we'll have enough.
I think we will.
(playful music)
Alright, orange me.
(laughing)
(steamroller whirring)
- It's here!
- Oh my God!
- I know.
That's the reason I wore this shirt.
We are ready to steamroll our artwork.
The artwork is about
seven feet by seven feet
and it took a lot of preparation
and a lot of hard work
and we're finally ready to flatten it
and see what happens.
- [Everyone] Steamroll!
Steamroll!
(steamroller whirring)
(people laughing and cheering)
- Hey!
Steamrolling me!
Steamroll two K 18!
(steamroller whirring)
- [Woman] It's good!
- Wooo!
(steamroller beeping)
(upbeat music)
- You can see it, look.
You can see... where the Starburst.
- Yeah.
- You can see the pattern.
Alright, hell yeah, oh my God, alrighty.
Let's peel it back this
way, peel it this way.
Oh my god.
(laughing and cheering)
(cheering)
Oh my God, it smells like Starburst.
(suspenseful music)
- [Woman] Good?
- We just smooshed probably
2000 of our 3000 Starburst.
The heart is the highlight
but overall, we had fun
and that's all that matters.
All in all, it was a success.
(upbeat music)
- Hey, Unsolved is on a new channel.
And now your part.
- [Both] Subscribe here.
- That was my part.